who is the bitterness director too
uh i think it's just i think it's just
women in general seeing
seeing them for what they are now you
know i had that whole one out forever
and believe the whole disney bull crap i
read my book
all of it i haven't got i was waiting
for the audio book i do a lot of driving
in the car
it's going to be out soon it's it's yeah
it's probably going to be out in the
next month or so it's it's
it's very close to done um i basically
closed the book with um
you know with the old adage like the
whole point of the red pill and
all of this knowledge is not to dislike
women it's
to not dislike them for what they can
never be to you right yeah because our
entire lives you know we've been lied to
sugar and spice and all things nice and
blah blah blah blah
and at some point where you're at right
now you're at the
end of the divorce machine you've spent
39 years on earth believing all this
crap and then
you come across some bald guy with a
beard on youtube that talks about stuff
and you go oh that makes sense
that now clarifies things now i'm better
well again the whole point of
all of this knowledge is so that you're
not angry at women
right that's not i i don't know if
bitter is the right word i'm not angry
at them i just you know every every
every instagram
chick has her butt and a phone in your
face and it's like yeah
i don't even it's just nothing i'm not
mad i'm just numb
i think cool okay so that's so that's a
totally different thing because
i'm the same way right i mean i i can
sit here and open up instagram
tick-tock whatever and look at this and
it's the same
it's the exact same carbon copy of one
chick
after the other check and they're all
the same right yeah you start to look at
it
start dating you know you start dating a
few women maybe they're around your age
and they got kids in tow and they got a
story and you start listening to you and
you're like
you're you're no different than my
ex-wife you're no different than the
last girl i did last week you're no
different than whatever
and that's just modern women today you
just accept the fact that
this is this is what we're dealing with
now that you understand what you're
dealing with then you start to dispense
fewer
f's around it and you go and reserve
that energy
you know those f's that you have for
something else maybe
maybe you go and join a car club maybe
you go and do rallies with other guys
and have some fun
um you know there's lots of options for
you to pursue
once you unplug from the narrative that
you have to find the
one that's going to be by your side till
death do us part and sickness and health
and richer and poorer and blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah and all that sort of
stuff right because now you start
putting yourself first
and then they start hitting you up
they're like hey chad hey chad
right and then they're like what are you
doing this weekend i like your car
can we go for a drive
i'm busy you know because you know it's
not worth your while
or you don't even respond you don't even
respond
when you get that text from that girl
that you were in an fwb
relationship you know friends with
benefits months ago and she hits you up
out of the blue and she's like
hey chad what are you doing tonight you
want to come over or can i see you or
something like that you're like
you don't even bother responding because
you've got so many other options that
are more important that are more
significant that are more fulfilling for
you
that align with your own mental point of
origin
just just keep focusing on yourself keep
working on the fact that the whole point
of all this is not to dislike women
it's to not not to dislike them for what
they can never be to you
once you've once you've blown up you
know the entire narrative of
you know the sugar and spice all things
nice and you know forever and ever till
death do his part blah blah blah
you're just gonna be like who cares
you could call it numbness you know if
you want you know if you want to call it
numbness fine but
at the end of the day it's just meh who
cares yeah
i kind of you know i kind of want to you
know i'd i'd like to date again but
um i don't want to be i don't want to be
the doom pill black bill
angry you know i don't want to i don't
want to be that well
i can tell you that the doomer guys out
there that are making all the negative
content
um they're not driving m3s right they're
not driving competition packed cars with
carbon fiber roofs and like you know the
20-inch wheels like
um i don't know if you caught the early
part of the stream
but i mentioned a a post that i shared
on the community tab with
sean stevenson and his number one lesson
is never believe
a prediction that doesn't empower you
and that's the problem with all these
doomer guys out there that are like
ah if you're not tall enough if your
name's not chad you're never going to
get laid
right you know it's like yeah i
appreciate the shout outs yeah
you are you are believing predictions
that don't empower you which is why you
suck
and you don't have to suck but if you
want to choose suck that's fine go suck
that's that's just the reality of it so
dis
just disconnect from everything else put
yourself first
and if you want to allow a check or
multiple checks into your life when
you're ready for it
make sure that you set boundaries and
you don't let nightmares in your life
you're divorced now well almost you know
you're divorced now
you got kids how many kids you got three
okay you
do you want to have more kids are you
done having kids okay so you're done
having kids
so marriage offers you nothing
sweet [ __ ] all there is no advantage to
you
at this point to ever get married again
right
so that's completely off the table so
when chicks are like hey well you know
chad i'd like to get married and have
kids because there's a lot of chicks out
there right now they're like 39 40 41
and like
i haven't had any kids because i put my
career first i've got three dogs and a
cat
but i'd really like to have kids and
you're handsome and your children are
beautiful so i want to have more with
you
it's like [ __ ] no i'm busy
i'm i'm going to the car meet this
weekend we're going to compare carbon
fiber weave on our roofs
okay i am busy i am going to watch
molasses fall
in minus 40 degrees centigrade weather
very slowly
you